hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to would you rather now I'm
gonna do this with as logical reasoning
as I possibly can I'm gonna take these
suggestions as being very literal in
their meanings so when this first one
comes up would you rather have triplets
or be a triplet I'm assuming that it
means I have to birth the triplets
either out of my butt or out of my dong
and both of those don't seem like good
options to me so I'll be a triplet
I'll definitely if there were three
Markab Liars which who knows maybe I'm
one of them considering I'm still a
child but anyway I'll be a triplet I
don't want to have to deal with that and
I don't want to have to spontaneously
grow a vagina to be forced to deal with
that so I'm not gonna do that
would you rather save the library of
exam exam three ax from burning or know
what happened to Atlantis okay number
one Atlantis blew up who the [ __ ] cares
it's lost gone who cares it's just sank
into the sea make up whatever [ __ ]
you want that's what happened it was
really cool the way it disappeared
whatever but if you saved the Library of
Alexandria from burning there was so
much knowledge in the Library of
Alexandria there was ludicrous amounts
of knowledge that was lost it would
change the entire course of human
history
at this point in time if the Library of
Alexandria was still around and
continued to exist then there's every
possibility we would be even farther
along in the technology progression if
this is Age of Empires then we are now
who knows what could happen or maybe
nothing but it's better than knowing
what happened to Atlantis oh come on
and lattice sake who cares it was
abducted by aliens and got blown off
into space
they made a nuke and blew themselves to
[ __ ] it was actually a city of aliens
and then they just decided all these
humans are [ __ ] in it where the [ __ ]
out air as what [ __ ] happened who
cares good would you rather drink a cup
of blood or drink a cup of urine okay
you're in is sterile who knows where
that Bloods from who knows what's in
that blood gross not gonna do that I'll
take the cup of piss never thought I'd
say you stupid [ __ ] bags oh no what
you're talking about it it's not animal
blood it doesn't specifically say it
says cup of blood as far as I know
that's one blood cell from every
creature that has blood whereas if I get
a cup of piss no matter if it's aardvark
piss if it's elephant piss if it's human
piss if it's dog piss if it's I don't
know praying mantis piss I don't know if
they even piss but if it is I know it's
sterile and there's nothing wrong with
it would you rather kill five people
with a knife or shoot ten people to
death I don't know the context of this
but what I do know from a very logical
standpoint is if you were trying to kill
people a knife is a really brutal way to
do it because you have to look them in
the eye
once you're stabbing them in the back
but you got to get really close to him
and that's that makes it just more
personal so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
do that although the volume thing but
you know I guess if I have to I'd do
five but I don't think I could hmm would
you rather eat a zombie or be eaten by a
zombie okay I'm assuming by eaten by a
zombie you mean that I'm awake I'm all
my intestines
I hope they taste bad for you or
eat a zombie potentially become horrific
ly infected in and I'm assuming that if
you eat a zombie you're gonna become
like one of those super zombies I think
that's how it works either way I'm gonna
die might as well be a cool super zombie
I suppose I mean I don't know if that's
actually the outcome but I'm gonna be a
zombie or dead I've done told to eat a
zombie who knows maybe their taste good
maybe they taste great
maybe cannibalism is fun would you
rather save Tupac's life or see Jesus
for two hours
who said Tupac is dead hmm yeah I'll
save him
I'll save Tupac would you would you
rather kick a baby full force or kick
two baby koalas to death so it's either
kick a baby to death or Creek a koala to
death to to to baby koalas I don't see
your way out of this one it seems pretty
cut and dry I don't think there's a way
out of this one I probably gotta kill
some koalas or else I'm gonna look like
a monster
Who am I kidding I've said I'd punch
babies in the face before like why am I
worried about kicking a baby [ __ ] god I
guess there's no guarantee that it's
gonna kill the baby I leading up to this
kick I would go around in a wheelchair
like full-time so that my legs atrophy
and I can't actually use them and then I
just have to like pick up my leg by my
arm and kind of swing it like a rope pif
and like give it a little kick on its
butt that's what I do oh yeah that's
right I've wanted to kick the baby
ah [ __ ] now that choice is burned in
everybody's mind would you rather get
swine flu or get West Nile the quote
there says you may die but in order to
get full context I need to know the
actual symptoms of swine flu and West
Nile all right what is swine flu
symptoms include fever cough sore throat
chills and body aches pain and muscles
can be dry cough diarrhea nausea nausea
vomiting honestly that sounds like the
flu it doesn't sound all that
bad why am I worried about that all
right how about West Nile fever
headaches body aches skin rash swollen
lymph nodes severe symptoms stiff neck
sleepiness disorientation coma tremors
convulsions and paralysis well that's
obviously worse
well that's a hundred percent worse I'll
take the swine flu bring it on
would you rather live in an abandoned
bomb shelter or live in an isolated
Tower I am going to go oh bunker is like
brendan fraiser cinematic masterpiece
blasts from the past which I have never
seen but I can only assume that is
mm-hmm
quality towers like Rapunzel but no one
comes to visit you or save you you have
commodities and access to Hulu but over
dial-up in both situations stuck with
Hulu [ __ ] ah yeah I mean if the tower
was like some old radio tower and I was
able to broadcast like my radio show
from there that'd be kind of cool but it
seems like the tower is uh like Rapunzel
which means made of stone and filled
with books and boredom so I'm gonna go
with brendan fraiser cinematic
masterpiece blast from the past bunker
because that sounds cool and maybe I
could gift everybody with my lyrical
soft voice throughout the radio waves as
I'm slowly going mad and masturbating
not particularly in that order
I'll take the shelter I guess would you
rather have sex with a fat ugly person
or have sex with a hot person that has
an STD this is why they make condoms
it's Judge it is the purpose of the
thing it's the purpose of it is this a
problem
I'm assuming this is a one-time thing
this only seems like a one-time thing so
like if I have the choice and it's right
in front of me I'm gonna take them I'm a
bum Obama bag it up would you rather
have a huge head and a small neck or
have a huge neck and a small head okay
this is a matter of engineering so I'm
gonna I'm gonna approach this logically
if you have a large head and a small
neck it's structurally unstable it's
just not possible to keep it up there
and have it in any sort of stability if
you get hit in any capacity in the next
shoulder area your head is literally
gonna pop clean off of your neck and go
flying and you're dead if you have a
very fixed firm neck with a very small
head you're like a missile you're an out
of crews in there you got a goal for
football you're gonna be great at it
because you've never gonna get any head
injuries on there or at least neck
injuries you can still bash your brain
around but you know you're gonna be
built like a tank and that's what I'd
rather have I'd rather be short ugly and
strong than huge headed and vulnerable
ready me I think I think I've got the
option of getting a huge neck and a huge
head I got the best of both world scan
you I'll take I'll take the huge neck
please thank you
okay everybody everybody's not thinking
logically about this all those people
are gonna be there gone next you're
gonna snap the second they walk out the
door if you were a woman would you
rather I'm not even gonna answer that if
you were a woman would you rather have a
vagina on your right hand or a vagina on
your neck and I'm gonna assume it's in
an inconvenient location like not front
or back side side it's like over here
now it's over here on the back a little
bit no it's under here like weirdly
placed and high up on the neck like just
very inconvenient like almost on the
chin but that's where a vagina is or on
your right hand I know this looks like
my left hand but it's it's my right
trust me
wait don't look too into this that's my
right hand cuz the way the camera does
it flips the image so like it's passed
by right hand I'm not an idiot here it's
all righty I know I know righty from
lefty okay I know that didn't help at
all
but to you lefty looks like left I'm
getting away from the topic let's get
back to the vaginas I think this would
be fine cuz you could either wear
scarves your whole life or wear a glove
it makes hand jobs real easy I guess
I'll take the hand vagina which is
another thing that I wouldn't have
thought that I would have to shout out
aloud on the internet to over a million
babel' would you rather be extremely
unattractive or be extremely attractive
but have a hand that smells perpetually
like poop does this relate to the
previous vagina one but instead of a
vagina it's just a butthole cuz I can
cover that [ __ ] up with a glove like
just the same I'd be hot as hell and I
have a butthole hand this is like weird
in my book
Wow would you rather have all the
phobias known to mankind or have to
slowly skin your family and pets alive
so the one is like a lifelong phobia of
every you're literally afraid of
everything mortally fear your skin
crawls no matter where you look and you
can't close your eyes cuz you're afraid
of the dark and you're afraid of being
alone but you can't be around people cuz
you're afraid of crowds like all that
[ __ ] or have to skin your family and
pets alive and they're probably gonna
die from that that that's most wrestle
your shirt so it's either a lifelong
thing or a one-day event of terror I'll
leave that one up to you guys cuz I
don't want to answer it so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what your answer to this horrible
dilemma is down in the comments below
and thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see
in the next video by
[Music]